you know how uh
christian like i kind of sit back and i
only say something if like they need it
or got to bring something up do that
[Music]
kyle you eat that ass or what i i have
not eaten that ass
oh because it hasn't been brought up yes
haven't started yet
i think it is on our to-do list oh it is
i think she's into that you're not
opposed to eating i'm not no i no i'm
definitely not and are you clear that
we're recording right now kyle i just
want you to be here
oh this is about her not some other girl
have you done it before i have yeah oh
my goodness
yeah don't mind it are you against i i
could not do it nick i feel like that's
an asian yeah is it i think it's an
asian thing no asian man i know is into
eating i have to have a couple glasses
of wine i will say see that i can't i
can't do it you don't have bone sober
who cares it's vegan it's vegan
though it depends on what she eats
that pizza
short king of course you eat ass
shortcake i mean short king part does
everything yeah i feel like white guys
are into eating ass yeah as a general
rule of thumb no
i guess it's two thirds i was gonna say
i'm not my thing someone's not your
thing i'd have to be in a relationship
where yeah i was begged
i was very intimate yeah
did you did you attempt it or something
jim no no okay the farthest i've been is
anal but even anal can get
a little odd you know asian man but i'm
down i still i still did it but still it
can get odd because you know what do you
mean
earthquake
huh where
no one felt
me doing this oh maybe
when you posted that picture in your
store was there an earthquake yeah when
it was super small it's like a 3.3 uh oh
yesterday the day it was yeah it was
like two days ago two days ago it was it
was super small but uh
yeah there wasn't you said earthquake
it's like out
every time there's an earthquake i post
a picture of the wrestler earthquake and
uh oh it makes me laugh i know he's
because you're pretty consistent with it
yeah i was like damn he's consistent and
i can try to get on there like i got him
i got earthquake in my favorites i try
to get on there oh do you really within
a minute of the earthquake happening oh
by the way this is cats after dark it
might be episode one too now that we
have one in the can uh okay trying to
get people acclimated with the regular
crew and then starting on guests after
they uh
get more familiar with us yeah this is
why you typing in uh
you don't know what he looks like nah
he looks like george george's dad yeah
uh from king and the stinger yeah george
shout out to george
in illinois
i this this time i post the one where
he's uh doing brendan's flex yeah it's
that fl the the
no no no no
it's it's right there it's right there
third picture of the right no he didn't
block though
there were a picture of the right that's
the one he posted yeah earthquake look
at that [ __ ] and then if you search
earthquake
there's like
all these people just on twitter it's
just like all these people like was that
just an earthquake was that just an
earthquake and then there's my picture
of the actual earthquake right in the
middle oh so yeah it gets up there right
huh it gets up there and then uh just i
i'm trying i go on latest i don't know
oh you're keeping his legacy alive yeah
you are you're single he passed away
like oh five yeah what did you say he's
dead yeah yeah i believe name a wrestler
you like from the 90s i know right he's
dead
besides the rock and mankind
still going strong early early early
okay
you're right earthquakes early 90s
huh brett the hitman heart still alive
his brother died his brother his brother
died yeah he brett seemed like he was
less on steroid although when you see
him now you're like okay he was big but
he wasn't as like cut up as some of the
other guys who were like i think not
like much what about my man razor ramon
he's still got that good hair uh i think
he's still kicking he was in he was in
rough shape for a while i think he was
like wheelchair
bound just because he was like so fat
and [ __ ] but then he started doing ddp
yoga and he
had diamonds diamond dallas page he was
a former wrestler the former wrestler
who started taking on yoga and
stretching and all all that [ __ ] and he
kills it mm-hmm yeah have you ever heard
him speak like on a podcast he's like
just so
dumb no no no
no
cool but we were talking about how chin
was saying it gets weird and anal and i
do kind of want to go back to that and
see what you meant by that i remember
the first time i did it i was not
prepared i thought it's going to be like
any other any other day whatever but i
work on them because i was also worried
that you know yes no just just some sort
of it's i don't know this you don't want
to know your dick yeah it's something
you might get an infection i have no
idea
he's like
[Laughter]
and then she cleaned out her
yeah she cleaned out she clean out
herself as much as possible
everything but then there's just a smell
i just i never expected to smell it
wasn't like bad it was just different
[ __ ]
but she cleaned it out so it's just
something to do with the ass i guess i
don't know that's why
when you guys say eating ass i'm like oh
my god
oh sorry it ruined your
i mean he didn't ruin it but it's just i
have to prepare myself for it if i do it
how do you prepare for that what what
are
i can imagine you having the
synchronized swimmer like little nose
plug that'd be so sexy right now
no i get it man okay so you guys are you
guys have done both i've given them both
either either
we're we're still on ass eating
no talk about just anal oh uh yes yes
what was it both
do they come in clear though i feel like
pink is about i know it's a lot of
distractions right here
there we go get your clear one she won't
know what's there would you be allowed
to watch wear that on fear factor i
guess it's kind of the same thing yeah
but see if it's clear what the [ __ ] is
this invention for eating closure no i
think this particular one is a like oh
to make a nose narrow situation yeah oh
so it probably like pushes your nose to
where it's like it makes it oh
yeah
yeah i could have modeled this [ __ ] look
at that black dude yeah all right shout
out to them killing it why is he greased
up for this i know yeah right like chips
oh no
that's the show it doesn't slip off with
sweat i was thinking of mike too i know
i was like yeah why is he all greased up
no i get it
you said you've eaten you've eaten ass
right yeah would you have your ass eaten
why not sorry fair enough why did you
ask him if he had his ass eaten
a lot of guys wanted their ass ate i
will say you know how uh
christian like i kind of sit back and i
only say something if like they need it
or got to bring something up do that
he came out
he came out of nowhere we're like
hey twice he brought it back to eating
it i know right yeah
gotta you gotta keep the show right yeah
yeah no yeah you you listen you were in
the right area what i wanted to do on
the first cats after dark uh was
and i talked to you about like bring in
the other behind the scenes guys well we
have kyle here so we can come back kyle
i don't think anybody's really gotten
his origin story but i wanted to bring
in like casey and mike but i talked to
casey he's like i just don't know if i'm
up for a podcast today yeah there was
some weird vibes in here oh yeah
so
yeah all right kyle what's your [ __ ]
oranges yeah welcome welcome kyle origin
story thank you guys for having me um
you're welcome
what is this [ __ ] jimmy
kimmel find your business
not to talk nice about you thanks for
having me man i appreciate you kyle
you're doing great yeah i grew up in
cincinnati my entire life uh shot
weddings previously and worked a normal
40 hour work week um and then i sent a
vinmo to somebody uh saying i like your
guys work i would love to come you know
shoot for brendan and whoever else this
person was kind of being an [ __ ]
today
and
you know chappelle lied for me and like
hey uh brenda and kyle's i've known him
for five years and you should let him
come out and take pictures and say i
know right he venmo me and i was like
why the [ __ ] you venmo me that's i
didn't know who he was that's called
networking i love that that's a dope
move isn't that crazy 15
is what got me relocated
sent me twenty dollars i was like yo why
did you video me twenty dollars you know
i've been trying to move to la my entire
life it just never worked out um and
that twenty dollars you know it took two
months and i've i'm gonna yeah full time
so you owe them 30
he sent yeah he sent me a dm
and i'm like we get dms all the [ __ ]
time for people
wanting to be like yo i take pictures
and i'm like yeah and you're like [ __ ]
you people you know
but then it was then he memored me and
that goes right to your notifications
because it's money yeah
because i was going to be like yo take
this money back you know whatever i say
yo why did you venmo me and i was like
do i know who you are or whatever i
think i said something like that yeah
you guys know i take pictures i see you
guys are coming to kentucky blah blah
but i actually wasn't going to kentucky
uh i had a different tour date or
whatever and so i just messaged brandon
i was like yo this guy takes pictures i
was like he's done it for gary owen and
uh nick um schwartzen swartzen or
whatever so i just sent it respect the
hustle man that's that's cool i used to
hit up people i i had linkedin premium i
paid 30 bucks a month for it and that
was like an you could do in mail which
you knew it would go straight to their
email which was like another way i would
hit people up that's the next level
the next level what a strategic way i
mean like have you done that before um
just to talk to just uh simping women
yeah uh just i'll buy a coffee here and
there no um
i did the same thing with justin
bieber's videographer and now we're
pretty decent friends
oh wow so you're two for two yeah two
for two on that yeah if you want to
network with people send them [ __ ]
money
i know you know what's what's funny is
my vimo is super easy to find you which
you're probably gonna need to change
your name now or i'll be out of a job by
the end of the day i know we're on the
screen i'm putting up all our venmos
when i started working with fighter and
the kid when i was working i was
juggling three to four jobs when i first
uh started working in podcasting because
i was only part-time with firing the kid
so i had all these other jobs because i
was broke and i was also taking care of
my ex-boyfriend and two people in l.a
very expensive uh one day i was at work
i woke up to an email and it says like
somebody sent me five dollars and i was
so confused at this point i maybe had
like
5 000 followers
and this guy just found my
like venmo account and he paid me money
and just said like hey i hope you have a
great day i posted it on my story like
oh this is a nice little surprise people
then found my venmo and started sending
me money so i put my venmo out there and
i made like two three hundred dollars
that
uh day which is great because i was
behind on bills yeah so that helped me
out so [ __ ] much that was the scene
like jesus christ
yeah
i had well i heard someone actually i
think i heard it on the yak the sparse
little show but they said it in in
passing as a joke but i actually think
this would be like a genius idea if you
like get
got a cardboard sign put your venmo num
number or venmo handle on it be like
some guy said he'd split the money with
me if you send me this venmo or give me
this money and you give it to a homeless
person on the street how does that not
make you a couple hundred dollars a day
i mean you know what there are fires on
that though some people use that venmo
and then request money because that
started happening shortly oh yeah yeah
people request money i'm gonna give you
more money
like what you really think i'm going to
give you money maybe i could even
know and it'll go to like cheering
homeless
yeah
hey just send me a hundred dollars not
eat a dick i don't know you like that
[ __ ] life they probably loaded they
probably just do that to [ __ ]
i need to change my vimo in cash app no
i gotta change my name no [ __ ] that bro
people requested like 200 ignore i get
requests too you get requests here yeah
when are you going to respond because i
i need to i do you know i suck at
responding eve okay i owed my tax person
i didn't pay her until like
five months later because i didn't see
the i never look at requests even my
girlfriend i
had to buy stuff or she had to buy stuff
and then she put the request in
and then i just didn't never paid her
how does your uh
because my taxes are getting more
complicated i've always used turbo tax
i'm sure i can't anymore yeah huh i did
i would use the turbo tax as well yeah
but it's getting like i don't know i
feel like i'm leaving money on the table
how do they how do they charge you
oh so she's well we know her very well
is one of our friends so she just puts
the the venmo request in and we just pay
her i don't know if i should say that
because uh well i meant more a little
more like how you know how do you tax
people charge is it like yes
yeah last time no they last time what i
just gave her all my taxes the chinese
people
two chinese ladies gave her out they
fixed everything they're like what's a
hundred something dollars or something
that's it just one time payment wow so
like what i have found that you either
do a retainer cost where you pay them
monthly if you have more tax needs where
they can check in with you because i
guess a lot of people who run businesses
will need monthly meetings with their
tax people to set side monthly costs a
lot of people do quarterly payments and
so you will pay them a retainer fee of
whatever it is they ask or you could do
your taxes all at once at the very end
of the year and then pay them the amount
that they just charge you just need to
know what they're waiting for
at the end of the year that's how is it
you did
what yeah oh no at the end of the before
the deadline yeah before the deadline oh
okay i was like what in december you
could just
pay your taxes
i mean if you're a contractor a lot the
smart thing is it's kind of like what
you were describing you do quarterly
which i need i'm like that's my goal
this year is to do quarterly because
doing one at the very end just hurts
your feelings oh my god i haven't made
so much money last year
i know and like
i'm on a payment plan
[Laughter]
i know
i know i just got my llc
oh that's good i'm excited what'd you
name it what'd i name it yeah am i
allowed to say it is it weird um i say
don't say it because if you have it
linked to anything that you're
associated with like um when i was first
signing up for my llc my uh tax person
told me like hey dude a lot of people
make the mistake of putting their like
address out there for different things
so like that's how people can trace back
like where you live or like home off
where your office is so i wouldn't
recommend putting that out there okay i
won't put that out there i don't give a
[ __ ]
because it's a funny it's a funny story
i wanted to be i love the quote by teddy
roosevelt uh is not the critical
accounts it's the man who's actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood blah blah so i
wanted something with arena i wanted it
like arena media obviously taken uh so
that and i don't know if you guys have
ever seen parks and rec but that one guy
starts a business and it's not real and
he starts it's like 720 entertainment
yeah and they they
they don't do anything john ralphiel the
worst i just have to i kept adding words
to it and it was some arena media
productions but on the thing you had to
write
i put arena media productions llc
evidently you don't need oh hello
so i am out of media productions llc llc
that is straight out of price actually
that's actually pretty funny yeah right
see you can say that no i feel bad you
don't have to not talk just don't
okay okay
well i thought you were sad i thought
you were sad i'm sorry the guilt is
eating away
no i'm good cool cool cool cool did you
ever watch the andy griffin show no no
what's that no one ever watched the
indie yeah yeah
you
you guys see what the [ __ ] was that i
got drops
oh that's what that's what yeah so what
you said no i was saying how dare you oh
i thought they were you know [ __ ] it was
greta thunder oh daddy
i thought i was having a stroke for a
second
how dare you uh fans out there if you
want any drops on the board i'm trying
to get i'm trying to add more uh
and uh but why did you bring up andy
griffith because he reminds me of
[ __ ] uh opie
is he the guy that talks like this no no
that's uh gomer pyle
type of ob
ron howard right it's ron howard's
channel as a kid obi taylor just have an
opie taylor give it a go
yeah give it a go is that your voice no
that's my name
[Laughter]
that's you
why i don't know it just reminds me yeah
you remind me of him
especially when you were doing the tough
mudder i was like he looks like a little
kid climbing across this [ __ ] ah okay
i did that [ __ ] though yeah you did that
[ __ ] right he did yeah you did very well
yeah okay so i
could is there are there two ways to do
it like could because you were using the
thing where you climbed up on the side
in that one could you also use the
monkey bars
oh and the thing oh because that's it on
his instagram yeah we were talking about
this yesterday and you're you're like i
was like i think i could do it you're
like yeah if you if you're like
moderately active you could do it but
what you were doing i do not think i
could do that it was like ninja warrior
like oh the way he did it oh yeah
actually the way he did it looked a
little bit easier
but i could get across the regular
monkey bars
oh [ __ ] those [ __ ] damn monkey bars
did you hey did you get across nobody's
well i skipped that one
there's one i skipped that i was like
bro but this make it no i tried this
yeah yeah so are you asking me
can you go underneath yeah you have to
do one on the side oh and the funniest
part is i had to jump to get on that oh
yeah you don't do the monkey bar part
that's what you're asking yeah yeah look
at the guys in the back i don't think i
could do that
look at the guy right there watch ready
watch him he's just jumping back and
jumping from like
damn
that's impressive
i don't know if you wanted to i straight
very impressive yeah i should have told
myself i said if i don't get this
[ __ ] wall first try i'm not trying it
again every obstacle we went up to i go
i won't do that
but i would end up doing them did you do
the wall did you get it yeah i got it
first try
nice
yep i told myself i said i won't do that
[ __ ]
yeah so i was like do a flip what
give me that
how tall is that thing meatball pretty
[ __ ] tall pretty [ __ ] yeah it's
pretty much a half pipe right it looks
better uh i think it's bigger than a
half bigger than half part
what are you wearing on your head
is almost like similar to the neck wrap
yep yeah but you just put it it's just
like that it stays on the entire time
yeah
wow that [ __ ] would you ever do one uh
yeah i think i i
where does he have a next one plan yeah
yeah in april outside of outside just
outside of l.a yeah i i might i might
yeah april 9th it was i mean it was a
lot of fun
actually actually
i was i mean i hated my life
but when i but when i got over it i was
like you know what you that was actually
what you hated your life you walked the
majority of it now yeah i still hated my
life you walked the majority i didn't
give a [ __ ]
i told you i was gonna walk that hoe it
was i will give it to you and jay you
guys said it'd be more fun if we walked
and we did have a lot more fun listen
listen the thing i would do next time
was is finish that two mile because like
you run two miles until the first
obstacle
you're just running oh really yeah the
the first obstacle isn't for like it's
like two miles away so you just running
and running and running and i said man
after the first mile i was like [ __ ]
this hoe and i started walking and then
but i think we would have done better
time
and honestly the other guys that were
with us i think they could have [ __ ]
their fans
i think they could have [ __ ]
finished up there we're like renting all
them but i think they were they just
wanted to [ __ ] roll with us
and they were just like [ __ ] oh yeah
they're making me try to make me go
first on every obstacle i'm like eat a
dick i'm not going first i'm not the
leader of this [ __ ] i'm just [ __ ]
hit the tear gas [ __ ] him up
they [ __ ] me up they actually tear gas
you not not it's like a man who was like
a menthol
cigarette to me but i i inhaled
because i went in with my eyes open and
it's all white on the inside you thought
it would get them high walking in i wish
uh i kept walking into the wall so like
i was like started to panic because i
couldn't find the exit so i started
breathing more i inhaled so much i could
not breathe it was oh yeah he inhaled a
lot it felt like um you know remember
back in like back in like the early
2000s like they had that like weird like
kind of blender thing you would stick
your face in if you had the whooping
cough
oh yeah it's like a
humidifier like if you um
damn it i know what you're talking about
the the
the cheap way to do it is like get a
a pot or whatever some water and put
like some water like put a towel in it
like that's it's like
yes this thing oh what the [ __ ]
yeah it's a humidifier that's [ __ ]
four thousand nine hundred what the holy
[ __ ] that's uh i'm doing better you're
gonna have a lot of weight i think
better karen
this is it this is it this is more like
it where
yeah yeah humidifier
it tastes like that but it's but it's
like a lot of it
it's it's it's a [ __ ] ton of it
and christian uh this is just like a
note for if you like
expand your fingers on the keypad it'll
like make it bigger over by the picture
so oh look at your christian deal he's
gonna be me pretty soon yeah god wanting
more handsome
and more jack i was oh this i was going
to ask you this when you were yeah
the wall thing uh and
do you and maybe this is second half or
you'll talk about public are you
using any performance in the answer
[Laughter]
and to be fair you talked about it on
fighter in the kids yeah
140 for a little bit uh but actually
tell us your cycle uh huh tell us your
cycle i was done i was done by the time
this tough mudder i've been done for
about two weeks three weeks so
yeah
i totally
oh yeah this is what i want to prove you
this was
hang on there's not that much of a
difference i kept talking [ __ ] as we
were walking
i was like well you look like there's
day one of it
that's day one yeah damn and then he has
a good face no home
this was
i think like two months in
wow yeah you look the same yeah
but day one you actually look buffy
but look his face look in his face he
looks confident he looks happier yeah
that was actually taken by kyle yeah
both of them yeah both of them are fire
photography
but i've gotten progressively fatter
through those two pictures
the race with the buttery bros um you
took that no no no that was that was
different different weeks
that around the same time
this one was on halloween
that one
yeah
do you have an interest
on starting something no no why not yeah
yeah what yeah what's your deal uh i i
i'm fine with it i want more of a kind
of cleaner
leaner cut look i'm not trying to get
like hey
there are steroids that will do that and
you don't have to get like big and bulky
yeah i don't even like
i don't know i don't even take advil i
don't really put you in my body we take
adderall uh-huh that's true
hey king of the jump rope right here
i've seen videos who are you i just yeah
i remember your videos back in the day
trying to train for now that we have
think boy studios we gotta get the
boxing match back but yeah it was it was
when i was photographed he can't even do
anything oh yeah yeah it sucks dude i
want to do all this [ __ ] he threw out
his neck i think a good boxing match
would be you and christian
who
yes nick and christian because i feel
like you both have like an unhinged
anger deep within and it's kind of an
even toss-up even though you have size
on it i feel like
it's like a lose-lose for me
no i like i i agree i actually think it
would be a good boxing match but the
size the optics yes i should win easily
so if i lose hey
tyson versus but i mean if you want if
you want to knuckle up
nick has anger for the last
of guy to four
somebody up nick is the type of guy to
kill someone on accident yeah yeah
that's the thing i did i went too hard i
went too hard i have 100 deluded myself
uh that i've watched so much mma i would
instinctually know what to do yeah
without any proper training it would
just come out it's true it does were you
were you that person as a kid that
watched a martial arts film and then
after it was done he was going around
the house [ __ ] it was more it was
more pro wrestling but yeah
that was i'd be powerbombing the [ __ ]
out of my pillow what's this i thought
what are you doing here oh i get choked
out by uh
john cruz tuck oh [ __ ] that's yeah i was
looking for this was yours
podcast
oh no
damn you look so young
i just smashed the box
a little arm track
i really am pissed because i was sure i
should have went out i didn't even think
about that like you should have like
passed out oh so you would not to not
tap you mean yeah yeah that would have
been way better
uh if i just let him choke me out that
would have been way funnier
honestly i thought you're gonna put up a
strong fight i mean judy act like he's
drunk though oh god i got it so they
created a scenario mm-hmm they're trying
to find some jump rings well you got my
little brothers
i've never put workout videos but i just
oh watch those guys i love these guys
what is this i haven't watched it in a
while oh i remember these kids uh it's a
muted
[Music]
it will come easy in life got to work
eat it out want to be the sack of the
[ __ ] by the face of the poor side
all right now we're not going to need a
star
take over everything
strength
[Music]
i love his enthusiasm
i'm ready for any challenge what year
was that do you guys got chills i got
you
it's just so weird
five years ago yeah my dad used to give
me the exact same type of speech as like
that little boy in the same doctor not
in the same uh accent but like the same
thing of like go work for like with the
same charisma so now i feel like a child
how long should i have been in the
states my dad has been here since he was
i want to say 21 when he came here he
lied about his age so he could go back
to school and get out your dad had you
late
yes late later he was i think
uh well in the grand scheme of things of
like comedians he's about the same where
he had me when in his like late thirties
mid to late thirties yeah but at the
time it was a lot like entertainment i'm
the youngest one even though he's the
oldest in his family among my cousins
he's the oldest in his family yeah he's
the oldest he has uh six siblings he's
like in his fifties he's in his 50s yeah
he might be brian's age if not a little
older
oh okay yeah
i'm going to check something real quick
what do you what are you going to check
oh just another studio oh hell yeah
that's what's up i like that
you know
check the studio your dad's not a
comedian right you were just comparing
because we work around companies yeah
because i feel like i have a skewed
perception of uh when people start
families or like settle down based off
of the world that we live in and kind of
like commit
like comedy entertainment industry
everyone kind of starts later in life
like settling down that makes sense
because usually like if you you know
depending on when you really started
like
your grind
or whatever like you start your grind in
your 20s
you know majority of times you're not
most of those people aren't going to
have
kids you know because they're so
committed to uh
you know the grind or whatever so yeah
it makes sense that someone in their
you know that yeah it's usually like
their mid 30s to late 30s where people
are starting to have some some of these
[ __ ] be cracking out babies in
their 40s mm-hmm janet jackson had her
baby at 50. brian just had another baby
he's 55.
i mean
50. he's 55. he's 55. yeah just turned
55. just dressed as 73 when that kid
graduates that's what everyone talks
about insane
that's wild and they're crazy
that's so crazy that's not far off from
theo's dad oh yeah
he was 70 when he had he was 70 when he
had thea when he had him just insane but
the used mom was of like pretty normal
age for that like range to have a child
right like she was in her like she was
38. oh 38 never mind 30 yeah because
what did they say
for women 35 and above
your like biological clock starts to
tick around like 28 to like 30. you can
still have healthy kids within that time
it's just the risk starts to increase
after your thirties after you're thirty
so it's very important for women who if
you wanna have a you wanna dedicate your
twenties and your thirties to your
career and have a family later to freeze
your eggs while you're still young
because this is what janet jackson did
probably i can see him you think she
froze her eggs yeah i think a lot of
females in the like this industry tend
to freeze their eggs did you know that
about janet jackson what that she had a
kid at 50 i did not you don't like black
people anyway
yeah it's very important i don't know if
i would want to freeze my eggs hey i
have a black lives matter and you know
that you know i support blm you do you
do i don't know
is it for content
he supports blm he doesn't support you
they're yeah then you don't support bla
you ain't real blm
blm i do think it's a little offset by
the fact that you were a kkk outfit on
oh yeah and it's his [ __ ] profile
picture for his [ __ ] instagram
i know i commented on what's so funny
what's so funny is when he said he was
going to be a ghost for halloween we all
were like
that's not a ghost
who were like what
that's a ghost
yeah he does have the birthday hat on
and yeah yeah yeah
you zoom out it does look a little
sketchy wait you commented on my poster
so
i commented my post and like you know
when you comment the picture is like
really really tiny you can't see that it
looks like ghosts so when i commented i
was like that does not look great yeah
it doesn't i was like but you still
decided to keep this as your
display photo yeah because it's funny
got it it was worth it
plus i haven't found anything better to
post
it's so funny because uh i'm thinking
about the tough mudder
[ __ ]
brendan had posted uh pictures
from the tough mudder yeah and there's
these comments like oh chappelle [ __ ]
backed out because i wasn't in the
picture it was just a couple hours back
that was a couple hours back yeah like i
was like [ __ ] you i did that [ __ ]
everyone trying to talk [ __ ] like oh you
uh who's uh someone let a comment hold
on
scroll and i never reply to [ __ ]
comments but i was like no one no one's
going to tell me i didn't do that
[ __ ] tough mudder one
i don't know now now i'm skeptical maybe
either
in the graduation sometimes people
sometimes people
oh there it is
did you guys ever get that pick from his
graduation i was a listener no we did
not we got a photo from his graduation
in middle school elementary school yours
mine yeah remember we couldn't find your
high schools
they were trying to prove that you
graduated and you never produced a
picture like back in the day
i'm just saying or no no he couldn't
find it
so chappelle never graduated as a fan
that's why i worked my way into this
episode are we about to build
nothing still no yeah still nothing i'm
just waiting
hold on you sound like someone we know
that kept lying about going to college
at a certain place man listen i know
what i did when i did it because i did
it can you not say that huh i don't know
that's fine what are you saying can you
say names we didn't say name it's fine
uh i'm not trying to start anything how
long have we been going christian 33
minutes
we'll switch over like five um we're
switching all this picture
super cat see i have no interest in
doing the tough mudder unless you have a
version of it that's similar to the
challenge because i grew up watching
reality shows like that and the
challenge was my [ __ ] that that would be
dope i want something like that my dream
is to be on the challenge but i don't
want it recorded i just want to do the
obstacles i want to see how i measure up
against somebody else with like tug of
war these like running challenges the
the trivia challenges and the puzzles
that's what i really wanna see if i say
private same team
they should have places like i mean they
have like axe throwing and everything
now you can go to why but like i want
this and i want tj lavin just like
watching me because i feel like i will
do better i don't want to disappoint tj
yeah that's the biggest thing he hates
quitters i want those two little kids
from that instagram video to watch me
send that again i don't know where that
went i do love tj lav and he's one of
the best hospitals i love tj lobby he
was the best
he is the best he's still he's the best
yeah he's still doing it still doing
that
i believe they're on paramount now
instead of mtv how's that his because he
had like bad brain injuries he had a
really bad uh bmx accident and they
didn't think he was going to come back
for another season because he had a lot
of uh brain issues with it but he made a
return and now he seems like you speak
normally and everything yeah wow that's
awesome yeah this guy yes love him i
used to have the biggest crush on him as
a kid damn
that's what i don't know about tj lavin
i love tj11
he's the [ __ ] what a weird career path
bro if you don't hit accept yo i'm about
to come over this table and
you're going to come on this time
what
we haven't got to that part of the show
yet three more minutes come on
what are you trying to pull up
okay
come on you got this yo
you know don't don't just [ __ ] keep
it to yourself
oh christmas oh chappelle
your glasses oh sorry
look at you oh [ __ ] them glasses [ __ ]
glasses
that's me you can't see it without
glasses right i mean i can do whatever i
want who's this
that's my youngest brother oh
uh that's awesome yeah youngest brother
he's
20.
guys
oh
my shit's so tricky because i went to
like
three different high schools and i had
to go getting kicked out yeah yeah
yeah we'll call it that yeah
but i had to go to this like bad kids
school oh it was like continuation
school yeah it's like a second yeah yeah
hey i was a lot less intimidated by you
when i heard you sneeze [ __ ]
it's so funny
you know that just reminded me of that
meme you ever see that mean when it's
like when your friends are roasting you
you don't have anything to say and it's
like this little kid that's just like
you never seen that it looks like
christian
when your friends are roasting you have
nothing no come back
i'm roasting you and have no
[Laughter]
so i just look like every white kid ever
with red hair
[Laughter]
you keep thinking he's a ginger yeah i
didn't have anything to say to him
making fun of my sneeze so that's the
only thing i could
christian
christian and kyle will you guys going
forward
uh fight each other no yes uh hook up
work on and give like a list of like 10
topics to cover yeah basically do what
we do for king in this 100 for this show
yeah and then he can have videos to fire
off just you so we like
have guidance yeah
we all talk a [ __ ] lot i don't know
on different shows
and then we all come to like a
screeching halt like oh yeah
are we in the second half yet uh yeah i
think yeah it's fine yeah all right so
to keep it moving then uh we'll do the
explore page thing where we pull up the
pictures of
the someone's explore page and we have
to guess who it is i know everyone's so
i'm judging everyone right now um but
you guys have to guess to see who's who
yeah and switch over to the super cast
now we're gonna yeah now
yeah that was a juicy juicy [ __ ]
i like juicy you learn a lot about
someone looking at their explorer page
oh yeah we're going to get to know you a
lot about someone various i think i
learned a lot about i don't i don't
believe in but also i don't i believe
you because i don't think you go on ig
that much no exactly that's another
thing you don't really post it yeah well
it's so it's easy
when you're like out fishing
yeah
i feel like you're on it more than you
because it also has access to like the
websites you visit and stuff so it goes
do you think maybe because i'm i you
know have to google [ __ ] all the time
for the show you know what it is i i
legit think the reason why your explorer
page is the way it is is because of the
things you have to look up while you're
out
so if it's connected again
see why chin is so defensive
[Laughter]
i pull one up
welcome back to the second oh actually i
think that on super cast it's just going
to be on all one
yeah one video so
all right so zoom it in
yeah so i think what in the world is
this one zoom it in you want to make
that full screen too um all right give
me one second then just so i make sure
that you can't see whose name this is
really quick smart smart
i don't want to ruin it for anyone
you ruin everything all right i don't
like how quiet it is who do you think is
going to have the weirdest explore page
out of everyone because we have i'm
already admitting it it's going to be me
probably it's going to
actually i can't give anything away but
let's just say everyone will be
surprised with the uh the answer
i feel like it's gonna be either chin
because of all the things he has to look
up for a fighter in the kid and it's
real
uh or i'm gonna think it's gonna be kyle
no i look up bible verses and things to
cook my girl so
thank you next question
no i feel like kyle's gonna have like
some weird anime [ __ ] on there nope
octopus
mine was actually a little more normal
than then yeah i had to cut out some of
the gym shark girls but the rest of it
looked pretty normal
all right i feel like jim shark's fine
there we go
you got this um you have it towards no
name
oh i could have just done this the
entire time are you [ __ ] me oh i
know who this is already
all right well hold on hold on so how
did you do that do what that scroll up
thing yeah that i'm a wizard
yeah you gotta tell me you're always
just
hey
is that a fingerprint the first one oh
all right yeah the first one um and then
does the thing i showed you about
zooming in yet okay
that's weird i don't know what that is
okay it's somebody who has euphoria in
their algorithm so someone fairly young
oh it's euphoria yeah those three
the the yeah that's euphoria and there's
a noseclass and then yeah i don't know
what there's a leather jacket with the
simpsons cop on it
but you're just looking up nose clamps
so what the [ __ ] is that
i want to know what this is because it
looks like it looks like their tongue is
going through there it's like a
bodybuilding modification where people
have like the circle gauges oh they're
like
right below their lip this is this is
why
you asked who is going to have the
weirdest this is this is the yeah
baffling i may have been certain yeah
what is this
uh when do we make our guesses yeah i
think we should i think we can guess now
okay i think
because it's a manchester music right
there what'd you say it says manchester
music so that's one of the things that
like search so i know that's why you
should have that's a giveaway i didn't i
didn't say
one of the things that goes on your
explore page is going to be based off of
the people you follow and what they like
and what they're watching
and i didn't realize this until my
sister told me that like she has a
problem with her instagram account
her explore page keeps showing videos of
people like
popping pimples and like taking out
blackheads like dr pimple popper stuff
and that's when it hit me
it's me because i watch all these things
i will watch dr pimple popper for hours
at a time i'm so nasty so that's also
why shapeless and so like you might be
getting everybody you might be getting
euphoria because like i watch euphoria
so that might be on your page because of
that that doesn't make sense wow but
yeah if you have any pimples popping
stuff on your page it's because of me
and i'm so sorry you know what
i'm gonna say this people think it's so
[ __ ] crazy that
[ __ ] pops up randomly on our [ __ ]
phones that you're like man i wasn't
even [ __ ] doing that and then you
when you narrow it back down making
people make it seem like it's the
craziest thing in the world and honestly
it's not that [ __ ] crazy like it all
makes sense of how it would happen it's
like linked it's like [ __ ] it's the
internet you know what i'm saying i
think it's just people are saying that
it's crazy that their phone tracks them
so much like say look something up on
google and then i see a sponsored post
on instagram that's kind of crazy
it's not crazy kind of like the fact
that it goes into your instagram too
like on a feed that you don't follow
though it's supposed to do that
oftentimes i don't i feel like it's
supposed to do that i remember
so i don't work for anybody either
people talk about them
actually listening and picking up
conversations i remember facebook got in
trouble for that years ago and that was
supposed to stop but people always say
like oh i said it and then it came up
but i think people don't realize they're
doing other actions like visiting a
website
uh or some like a bunch of other things
besides just saying they're like oh i
only said it out loud but it's not like
that that's the first time you had that
being a sinner looking up porn
well yeah i was going to say your phone
actually does listen to you if you have
the hey siri feature on your phone your
phone's listening to you 24 7 for the
words hey siri so also uh you guys were
telling me the alexa yeah oh yeah
yeah and the uh echo listen to what
you're saying yeah that's supposed to
help you to [ __ ] out and narrow down
what you [ __ ] like my dad would nev
well growing up my father never let us
get an alexa just for that reason my
grandparents
huh yeah it's weird did you hear that
growing up i wasn't allowed to let you
know growing up i didn't have an
election yeah right yeah i mean like
growing up like when i lived home my
parents i know but it just it's just so
weird but like my grandparents had one
wait when was one of them created
uh fight
2010 yeah yeah yeah yeah right right
around that time what year did you
graduate high school 2017
what
yep
wow yeah um but my grandparents uh found
out that when they're old so like when
they got the alexa
they didn't know what it was
the moment it found out it was recording
them 24 7 they threw that [ __ ] in the
garbage asap it was kind of funny
but also that's what it's supposed to do
yeah how else is that how else is that
thing supposed to work is it supposed to
not you think it's just randomly like oh
i'm this good no it's listening this is
good and then they're back it's like
buying a toaster and then throw it out
because it burns
i kind of do take a little credit for
them throwing it out too because
whenever we would go to our grandparents
house we would when our parents and them
would be in the dining room me and my
brothers would sneak into the living
room where it was and we would be like
hey alexa at dildos strap-ons like the
most wild [ __ ] to the shopping list so
whenever my grandparents would be like
alexa read me the shopping list they
would say like eggs strap-ons packing
like the most what does that [ __ ] have
to do all day besides just sit there and
listen that's right she's probably not a
[ __ ] but no she's you know what i'm
saying she always has that attitude i
don't like it whatever do you see what
i'm saying though am i crazy for saying
this no because i just don't think it's
that crazy yeah especially in this day
and age yeah like where wilder things
are yeah there's wilder things out there
but it was crazy for the time it was
released i will say like back in 2014
before any of this technology was kind
of readily available for you to have at
home i don't think people expected them
to like have a machine listening to them
24 [ __ ] seven yeah now it's much more
normal
i haven't adapted to a lot of like i
don't use siri or an alexa and it's
pretty convenient i used
and for a while can figure out the raise
thing and you can't go back oh yeah
there's no way to scroll yeah i think
it's disrespectful yeah because you have
to you have to hit play again to [ __ ]
you can't like rewind this message oh i
missed this part what they say right
there no i have to listen to the [ __ ]
minute voice
memo they sent and hammond and han
[ __ ]
arms and [ __ ] yeah um
hey nick um
and then
at the very end it's like a number 6.3
yeah
i do like that on a voicemail your
iphone will transcribe it and give you
that phone number for you just click
love that oh yeah it doesn't change my
life voicemails give me so so much
anxiety but when you can read it it's so
much better i know you could do that
yeah it's good to know yeah yeah all
right well you don't check your messages
so oh this is easy so this is going to
be the next
explore page we're going to look at
um let me just crop that out he's that
kid has blows on two
yeah when a couple days ago he's like
i've been looking at westies a lot i
think that was not your story
look at this kid think it's adorable go
to the right
the right yeah top right top top middle
i i had a feeling this would all be
pretty obvious
uh wait did everyone guess
you you right you oh
no no it's nick
oh that was christian
i thought it was christian because he
was awesome i thought everybody was on
the same page
i also saw his thing before and i didn't
want to see him also the little dog so
what his little icon at the bottom you
got to crop all of those out god damn
i didn't see that
chris you suck it's still just
guessing i mean i guess that one you
guys didn't know there's a lot of dogs
little dogs i've been watching a lot of
westy content
i get it
pull up another love trying to give me a
minute hang on
dude all right everyone close your eyes
okay all right and make a wish
i wish you'd pull it up faster
was that too far
hey man we're playing heads up seven up
oh i used to always cheat in that game
oh hell yeah come on i would always look
at the shoes do you think i would be
honest that heads up seven up hell no
i'm looking at the [ __ ] come on
christian it's true it's not going up
hang on give me a second give me a
second that's christian right now yeah
you know what i mean
there we go oh no my phone died i had
the prices right losing horn on here or
my computer died on my board
or just zoom into it
you think you could do better
chappelle is technologically uh now
everyone can launch chapel you don't
even know how to post a [ __ ]
instagram story so i don't want to hear
it what the hell
food models cards that's cat
oh i was thinking bronco too though the
hell yeah
who's this
oh
never mind that the million food food i
i would say cat
[Music]
and the belly button
nikki
right yeah who is this
i don't know
great tits
great great i'm glad someone said it
yeah great
so that is your cat yep that's me i
figured too hey oh yeah
yeah
for sure
next we're already narrowing it down
pretty much so everybody's gonna know
all right all right right for stuff like
this i feel like we need to write down a
list and then reveal the list at the end
i think that's what we're gonna do next
time yeah
we're working out
we're working out the kings
unfortunately you can never really do
this game again but uh well with
something else yeah yeah we'll uh any
time we have a guest i want to make them
put their make them uncomfortable
yeah i have no fear with my explorer
face man sometimes i'll uh like random
people's [ __ ] instagrams
christian this is christian
nope
wow this is the same girl the same girl
same girl this is a different explore
page uh r kellyann no i said can we sing
that song oh okay okay
oh this is that this is
nope
i can't i don't even know who this is
no it's he's the only one that left we
have a guest and cat said if anything
she's feeding probably goes to chins
also so that's [ __ ] yeah it's probably
an elimination that had this on the same
profile no crazy
why is there a fake foot next to uh mark
bell though where see that fake foot
thing oh that's weird-looking
chin what are you doing oh it's a
prosthetic
see how they they lost the big toe yeah
did you lose a big toe what's happening
how why in the world would that be on my
page that's a great i don't know chin i
should
i should be surprised but that that's
funny to me that you know who mark bell
is just like
yeah uh oh not from like being on the
show
i know that i know a power
yeah i have a lot of mutual friends with
uh mark bell because i hang out with the
jk crew and they're all power lifters as
well i saw well i don't know which one
it is okay love jk i don't know i don't
know what it is jk news they're funny
yeah theo's been on uh eric griffin's
been on kaleila and bobby have been on
they're great oh i never
and now they're gonna go on i'll hook it
up i did bad friends oh yeah jk news is
huge
they're doing a uh like relaunch now
because they lost access to their
account for almost a year for something
do you know anything about the drama
that went down between them
uh kind of but not really i came in just
around the time the drama was happening
so i don't know too much about that what
i will say is behind the scenes they're
all so [ __ ] nice and really don't
talk [ __ ] about anyone they're really
just talking about like mma hospital
like what they're up to
yeah i don't know why i said it like
yeah they don't like they're genuinely
people who just don't talk [ __ ] about
other people that's different it's dope
they're such a nice
talking [ __ ] is boring i love talking
[ __ ] i don't know
i'll tell you later
[Laughter]
but no i think within the confines of
like
me and like the people i gossip with so
like really just like stevie and my
sister because those are the only people
i really talk to yeah like i love
talking [ __ ] i love gossiping just
because it's like a fun thing that my
family had done when i was a kid so like
it's almost an activity yeah as long as
it doesn't spill over in other aspects
of my life and i'm not like moving
around the world like talking [ __ ] to
people and like being a negative impact
in the world i think it's fine
earthquake earthquake
no she's moving her hands and shaking
the desk
uh can you make a full screen yeah
what is that uh
let me make sure oh it's definitely a
topless lady
this isn't mine but that william default
thing was up on online yesterday willa
was a young man look at him look at the
hair you guys know where he's from um
where look that girl who's topless
hit play on that i can't screenshot you
boomer
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] yeah there is power
damn christian look at your searches dog
it's connor and a bunch of tits
right so that is christian yeah oh [ __ ]
can you just bring up chins that's the
big reveal yeah that definitely is the
big group we saw we saw a chance
i wasn't nervous i was just like i don't
i don't believe it i don't believe the
explore page and now we figure it out we
don't believe it it's all like a mixture
of everyone else's stuff and yours is
less accurate because you said you don't
go on instagram so it has like less data
to work with
do i still go on instagram but i don't
like i'm not i don't think i'm like i
don't know about you but you guys
everyone else you're not browsing every
night oh we're selling this we already
know it's me i'll show you guys what
else is on my explore page just for
shits and giggles
let's see if there's anything oh juicy
no
there you go why does everyone have that
little thing the little skin tag thing
right go down that that little thing
yeah what is the thing every we've seen
she though
she's cute very pretty girl but what is
that how much is she decorated
decorated yeah that one is so weird it
seems like not a real picture can
someone check it later on oh yeah it's
probably not good
uh that that one
you said it was skin tag that looks
weird [ __ ]
or war i wonder if i can maybe nah i was
gonna say maybe i could uh reverse
search it on google but it won't take
too much is it still on there oh no
unless you've refreshed it what else is
juicy anybody want to confess secrets or
something secret yeah oh should we talk
about confessions
also secret about what i feel like when
people ask me these questions i go i i
draw a blank i need something more
specific yeah more like a secret about
like the time you're in like tell me a
little bit about yourself yeah i don't
know
what do you want what the [ __ ] i need a
specific yeah secret
oh oh yeah i thought there would be more
that juicy [ __ ] we could go off you
ain't got no juicy [ __ ] christian you're
[ __ ] 22 years old
i'm an open book though i don't like
hide anything i say everything oh but
yeah what's up do you choose do you know
if gianni is going to go to uh all-star
weekend it's in cleveland and mgk is
performing he so he actually is landed
today
in la he's going to be here for today
and tomorrow and then he's taking a
private jet with kells and all his boys
friday and going on the all-star game
that's [ __ ] dope yeah that is a
little jealous i'm not gonna lie
that's not gonna lie but uh i think my
dad might be going to i don't know how
the [ __ ] he got tickets but i'm gonna
see if i can bum one off of him and see
if i can maybe go
they make you feel like a loser or what
no no no i'm used to it i'm used to
feeling like a loser because i hang out
with you all day so i gotta i hang out
with losers you know
i don't know anyone in this world who
riles you up like more than a christian
you're usually such a stoic like very
level-headed person and then you meet
christian and suddenly like your anger
management just like yourself
the dog on fighter and the kid today
also felt the same i know yeah no i i
got mad at christian when he was talking
to stevie weebies
uh like
friend or neighbor i have no idea i
thought it was like his caretaker or
some [ __ ] i understand if you want to
like jerk off [ __ ] francis nagano or
whatever but this guy
was stevie's neighbor
and he was excited to meet him no no i
was new and i didn't know who he was so
i was just trying to be nice to him
he could catch her however he wants he
had very specific projects he had to get
10 people into a zoom chat this is the
type of inner work stuff i want to build
this into so don't take it too hard
but i did he he did like i like snapped
and i've never done that on anybody and
i was like christian quit talking
oh in the zoo they were talking about
being from rhode island and [ __ ] and
like going in an entourage probably i
just didn't know how to like end the
conversation with a guy without being a
douchebag like i felt bad see i feel you
on that because uh every time you and i
have conversations it's always about how
like socially inept we are and how we
don't know how to socialize with people
properly i have that exact same problem
i will drag a conversation on for hours
out of the obligation of trying to be
nice to someone and it's [ __ ]
exhausting because i know i'm i'm just
like spewing vomit out of you yeah but
and i'm making hard eye contact all the
time yeah look at me
what was it that cracked me up the other
day or maybe go christian why are you oh
we were doing the tough mudder and then
they were explaining like oh this area
is like the ghetto
and then you're like what type of ghetto
and i was like well because like dude
there's so many [ __ ] references to
ghetto
christian yo
you're gonna tell me
that this looks ghetto to you hey
they're from around out there
yeah that's why i was asking like what
type like what ghetto could this be i am
i'm a little high so i don't know if i
spaced or you guys didn't give context
what are we talking about so
we would say oh wait we just talked
about how christian ralph's base
that's fair so whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa i want you guys to know he's not a
[ __ ] saint i'll wake up to a talk at
seven in the morning
first thing you see hey you're [ __ ]
ugly just remember that i'm like the
[ __ ] did i do
that's really buddy
look here i am having a great day i just
talked to my mom she's like oh i hope
you have a great day today you look
handsome and then i get a text from
chappelle 10 minutes later don't listen
to your mom you [ __ ] ugly
he's probably working this stuff you say
don't listen to your mom no
i just said you're not married i just
texted you as [ __ ]
that would be a funny little addition
i do deserve it because i do [ __ ] like
this if it will i mean you know i'll
just [ __ ] do like what
mine won't it pull over our text will
get cancelled no i'm just gonna show the
i changed the so he would always call me
ugly so i changed our group chat name to
the dollar store version of michael
then he made it a [ __ ] made the icon
michael no that was casey that was casey
oh you made it
look if i type
in what you could do that michael
strahan's success kind of baffles me
the man has does it he has hundreds of
millions so just what does he do he
seems like a very silent successful man
who just like does hosting gigs yeah
and he has this uh exclusive
a lot of his money is this exclusive
line of suits i think it's in jc
penney's or something yeah that's his
company and he's just made absolute bank
of that and now like i don't know his
the hosting gigs he gets are like the
biggest and
wait hang on real quick this is what i
wake up to
just from chappelle what did i say
christian is your busted ass awake
[Laughter]
and what time was that
um i don't even know sometime in the
morning
that's like having david 6 23. that's
like having david
that's too early
[Laughter]
michael strahan stay that way well you
got to realize that text at 8 23.
i'm already up at like [ __ ] 6 30. so
i've been up for a few hours
and you're just thinking about how ugly
i am like well i wake up and i go man
christian ugly [ __ ]
wait what do you want me to look up his
network
you can't trust this stuff though oh you
can't not really what does it what does
it does they have a number though i'm
curious what it says i also
i mean this is the sun
what does it say
uh six he's 50. when he played for the
while he played for the nfl he made
roughly 60 million
right
why is this a question did michael
strange go to space
nick you would know this more than
anyone in this room was he a beast oh
yeah he is the uh i think it just got
broken possibly by aaron donald but he
had the all-time sack record
and he got it in the last game of the
season against the packers and brett
favre and him were like friends and the
packers had the game in the bag they
could have kneeled they could have ran a
couple more times and ran out the clock
but
brett favre ran a naked bootleg so
michael strahan could get a sack at the
end of the game to bring oh that's
terrible uh that's awesome damn
some some people what's a naked bootleg
uh like the quarterback rolls out he
just doesn't have anybody blocking for
him it's like he rolled out to michael
uh michael strand's side you'd usually
do it like when you're throwing or
sometimes oh god or or like uh at the
goal line you'd fake a hand off and then
just naked boo you're saying brett favre
wanted to give that to him yes yes
that's super got it oh some people were
pissed about of course especially with
betting or whatever yeah and like i
think it was bruce smith's record that
he broke um and so people are just
pissed those fans did he win any
championship straight
i think so i
i think he was on that team that
when the giants beat the
patriots him and kelly ripper got beef
huh
yeah i think a little bit for that uh
show he won in 2008.
yeah that was that was the
patriots
16 in one season he was on the patriots
uh no he was on the giants who beat the
undefeated patriots oh [ __ ] or 1801
patriots
damn shout out to michael strahan i was
always so afraid of football growing up
because when i was a kid there was the
oakland raiders and the 49ers in san
francisco so every time they played each
other it was called battle of the bay
and so many families were like very much
like i'm a niners family or i'm a
raiders family people would get like
jumped and stabbed over this game oh
yeah so like raider fans are [ __ ]
raider fans will stab you in the neck
for looking at them the wrong way like i
am terrified of raider fans and so
[ __ ] don't even play
yeah so to me like football is a violent
[ __ ] sport for other reasons
i'm terrible are they still like that
raiders fans uh uh not so much anymore
but like those in vegas now yeah
they move but i don't know why they they
just had that that reputation i think
it's because it's like oakland and then
you're also in l.a like l.a
adam corolla had this joke and i think
i'm butchering it but it was something
like
if you want to get rid of all the
deadbeat dads have free cockfights at
oakland raiders stadium
[Laughter]
he would say something like that uh yeah
um this is gonna be like
are there any famous like asian football
players just that one uh punter right oh
well now he's not really famous the most
famous was vietnamese that new year no i
think so i think that was like that
straight
yeah asian football player batman a a
asian nfl player do you samoan uh i
don't think no i some owens identify as
a pacific islander so no but we are like
adjacent yeah distant cousins
because there's a lot of samoans lots of
simon see they're always happy i love
saying this
that guy does not look yeah i think he
looks mixed yeah
yeah
he has a similar mixed look to me what
i'm just in interviews he's pretty dumb
oh he feels like he's just looking at
him i was like damn i was like damn
[ __ ] up i was like me with christian
no no like uh so i thought i thought
murray was gonna be like the truth and
then he just [ __ ]
just had a garbage game and they started
seeing interviews that people had before
and i was like man if i would have seen
these there's no way i would have
thought he was a good quarterback
because like most quarterbacks are like
[ __ ]
smart yeah like uh
name a name name they're at least like
good interviews you know they're like
these comfortable cool guys whereas like
you like dan patrick made him like
wanna i don't know he just wouldn't give
him anything and part of my take he did
the same thing i think he blocked big
cat for her
and that just shows you don't get it
like have a sense of humor like when
they're doing i don't know
you got to embrace that if you want to
like grow your platform since we're
thinking of asian athletes i was
thinking about that one that he played
for the diamondbacks are you a baseball
guy nick uh
no not really i know i know baseball
players he threw he threw in like a very
crazy way the way he would he was a
pitcher diamondbacks yeah
asian
asian baseball player that played for
the diamondbacks japanese guy
i don't know
ishii whatever
he just threw in a [ __ ] crazy way
she's a hero
oh christian yeah are you typing this
who
[Laughter]
for diamondbacks diamondbacks
are you talking about the guy started
with the rangers oh he's the korean
yes the the top one
this guy born young kim yep yeah he
threw in a crazy way too he looks hella
korean he's korean that's korean that's
a very korean face yeah is that a korean
that's a oh good yeah korean name i'm
just saying like if i just saw him in a
room i would think he's korean yeah oh
really yeah a lot of asians can kind of
identify each other so was kylo murray
the only person that came up for
football players nope uh we just i just
went oh yeah who is it yeah
eugene chung that one
wow look at him he's black in asia i
think he's straight a full no i mean i
feel like he's been unless like he has
something like blocking his family from
the vietnamese war that tends to happen
a lot in vietnam you see a lot of black
vietnamese people around there
in vietnam because from the war like a
lot of women
local vietnamese women see if there's
there's like no pictures of anyone i
know those names even are they right
this is ranked it's the best asian
players
[Music]
black i think
uh mine's worth so most of them are
mixed yeah always i mean
except for yongoku that's the one that
you're talking about right now the fifth
one or the third one in he's a punter
yeah he's straight up korean too
yeah look all the other ones like i
didn't even know this guy what about
troy palamallo would he be pacific
islander as well yeah troy yeah yeah
he's another samoan yeah guy with the
guy with the hair basically i i love the
google names toyasa susopo polo
i played a lot of madden
who was your go-to player at madden uh
it depended on what season it was i
would always just pick a shitty team
that had a lot of fast players and
started a franchise with them
and then simultaneously started packers
franchise but they were always good so
it was less fun
have you heard ronda rousey's and um
travis brown's
baby's name oh it's a hawaiian name
right because yeah he's hawaiian
it's not even a joke yeah
see that's how i know nick's has been
around a lot of asian pacific islanders
he knows terms that's the name
all right who wants to try and pronounce
the entire name that's easy that's
literally that's a joke
puppy
[Laughter]
reminds me of the scene from for getting
sarah marshall yeah yeah fish yeah wait
wait wait wait wait i tried to memorize
that the other day yeah
and i forgot it the
because it it's cited in two different
things that people know i think it's
pitch perfect and for getting sarah
marshall the state fish of hawaii is yes
yeah then he said all right let's i
gotta hear someone say it is that
i'm gonna get canceled for dude
it's second half maybe it's fine
and it's close like i've been
you can see the name right there though
yep right there that 22 second video
can we play this yeah
yeah they're going to be on supercars
give me the same energy as you is that a
pretty funny movie oh it's one of you
never seen it it's very good
because you don't see any good movies
you need to watch it it's it's a good
one you'd laugh through that you roll me
up
good
how can i have terrible taste of movies
if i haven't seen it
yeah not watching movies does that mean
yeah yeah
what have you seen that you like
this will decide
people like that and i haven't seen two
stones
i've not seen that one
my [ __ ]
oh yeah you've talked about this before
that trailer looks kind of weird nerd
you [ __ ] nerd you
have you seen whiplash
edwards
drummer what's yours no i i heard that's
really good yeah unreal can we go around
the room and see what stop
[Laughter]
wait let's go around the room and say
what our favorite movie is because i'm
actually really interested can we say
tap three because yeah top three i'll do
yeah i gotta do the top top three yeah
okay which is your hands number one
what is number one edwards
that's cool
um what's that movie with christian
slater and marissa tillman uh
[ __ ]
this she was working on a diner i know
what you're talking about untamed heart
is number two i definitely have never
even heard of it
[Laughter]
can i say something real fast yeah yeah
i think marissa told me fine as [ __ ] i
had such a big crush on her that's why i
kept watching your movies have you ever
seen the wrestler
no yeah that's just your favorite the
new spider-man movies oh beautiful she
is gorgeous
look at her look
and my cousin vinnie when she was oh oh
my cousin vinnie when she breaks down
the car yeah she's so good oh gosh there
was a lot of controversy about her being
in spider-man because the role that she
plays is aunt may and she was always
played by like a an older woman like a
grandma woman
and
then she's just like a bombshell she's
yeah i know i'm so much better yeah so
much more such a better movie viewing
yeah definitely
i don't have an aunt now it's like like
in retrospect
especially if he's supposed to be in
high school also how do you want aunt
may to be remembered [ __ ]
oh but it was because they adopted him
she went from this
i know yeah yeah i mean i do get it
click that third picture to the right go
uh go back
what's your third favorite oh
right there right there right there
comparison yeah now let's zoom that in
which which aunt may you want right this
one duh which anime you want the one
what that almond looks creepy huh yeah
like evil that's her new spiderman right
there yeah that's her right now in the
news spiderman she looks drop dead
gorgeous i think she's
much more beautiful now as she's getting
older than she was when she was younger
even though she was a smoker
unless her 40s yeah
let's see how old she is real fast
51.
i'm gonna say
45.
he's in her 40s 50 57. [ __ ] she's older
than brian she's older than brian and
she looks like that god damn i can only
pray 50 seconds anywhere nearly i still
holler
absolutely
damn jesus all right nick next nick what
was your third yeah i don't think i have
a 30.
[Laughter]
hey i don't like anything after that
yeah and a little sister's hand and a
movie about a guy
so his parents giving up number three
yeah come on you don't have you don't
have a third one i'm trying to think i
mean i was i was blown away when i first
saw the first jurassic park i just
couldn't believe how amazing it was your
essay park is a great great movie yeah
that's better than a guy with a baboon
heart i will say that
what do you got nick dark knight
departed and dumb and dumber wow
gosh he's got great ones oh good
kyle mine's probably a little nerdy
thing about me i have 4 000 dvds and
blu-rays yeah like just shelves of them
but probably good will hunting
jim carrey the mask
and probably the ringer
which i'll probably get canceled for
because all of these are one yeah that
was actually that was [ __ ] hilarious
what were the first two i was um i was
swelling just swelling
i was no i was drawing on the four
thousand movies
that's like eighty thousand dollars it
was it was a little you started you
probably started to collect for
bargaining blockbuster was going out of
business i i robbed them you know um
goodwill hunting oh love it um and uh
what did i say after that
oh jim carrey the mask
i'd have to say the town
of course um happy gilmore
and
[ __ ] nick already said one of them [ __ ]
he'll still be your favorite too though
they departed by far oh yeah it's great
wow so yours was angus angus tombstone
tombstone
and the third one [ __ ]
i hate it because denzel has such a
[ __ ] catalog
and there was
when the pandemic first happened
like there was like where everything was
just shut down
i was running it just with [ __ ] all
denzel [ __ ] movies he's my favorite
actor gosh he is [ __ ] amazing
all
right i'm gonna have to go with ah that
one's good
like flight's good [ __ ] oh man
this is my dead zone pressure
he does that when he's thinking
that's what i did
uh i'm gonna say ah
you know i'll say malcolm x
solid
yeah
cat um i would say
the mummy with brendan fraser
love him
uh
that movie actually made me want to be
an egyptologist when i was younger the
mummy oh the mummy yeah i want to be an
egyptologist when i was younger and then
i realized you're just in the desert
like doing nothing so i want to be wwe
diva instead afterwards that also didn't
work out close i don't know
and then i would say wolf of wall street
and the third one
i have to say deuce bigelow the european
gigolo because i watched that movie
maybe like 70 times it was like on
repeat in my house when no one wanted to
babysit me that was really what it was i
love writing
yeah i see the first one never seen a
second one i really i really loved uh
hot chick hot chick is great that was
one that was a good movie i loved
a stapler yeah
because he just kept doing these things
yeah he was like oh yeah he's not chick
he's like yeah he's hot chick he needs
like prostitutes
yeah yeah sorry but what were you saying
about uh hot chick oh i just love that
that's that's a fun [ __ ] movie i also
really like mean girls i love music is
one of my favorites i remember that
scene where there were the two
vietnamese girls cussing at each other
over dating the uh the coach yeah and
being blown away because i was maybe
about nine or ten and they were actually
vietnamese girls like costing each other
out in vietnamese like i understood it
yeah and then uh that scene yeah yeah
and it made so much sense because girls
because they're like
uh yeah the pe teacher
what did they say they were like uh oh
you're jealous because all the boys want
me and she basically said [ __ ] please
in vietnamese and it's so on brand
because girls at that age like high
schoolers
where i grew up at the very least we're
dating like 23 26 year olds so like that
made perfect sense to me in my head i
was like yes representation matters i
had the [ __ ] hots for lindsay lohan
yeah oh my gosh what what year what year
[ __ ] mean girls year okay yeah mean
girls yeah she was killing [ __ ]
i think i had like a picture of her and
like
where was it oh it's on my myspace you
know like you could put pictures and
decorate it i think like in your bio
lizzie lohan i could i'd probably find
the picture you could probably google it
lindsay lohan
type of bathing suit
uh
i don't think that was a scene of me and
girls no it wasn't a mean girl it was
just like a picture she took not in the
room okay found it found it yep that's
the picture
armor oh yeah i know well it's from
rolling stone oh it is yeah i worked at
the library what's she looking like now
what's she up to now
she's so she looks very like
like
yeah she's very thin now sounds like a
recovering addict
yeah she got instagram you don't want to
no just remember that way
[Laughter]
there's a lot
that says the same thing i want him to
remember
a few years ago she was kind of going
through it because she was like
recovering from addiction but she's like
no she looks amazing scrolls christian
come on man
i thought it was a or i think i'm a year
younger than her yeah and like i've
loved herself yeah we like like
parent traps oh that's like she was
like we're about 12 and like and so and
then we we grew together
right i was a fan dude
hey chris stop [ __ ] around
trying to scroll back up bro
have you guys seen her in uh as hermione
and snl no i haven't it's such a good
sketch and she looks so freaking hot
because you know everyone liked hermione
like even adults when they were watching
like she's like she's a cute girl
whatever the way they did it on snl was
freaking oh i think i have i have seen
that who who plays there
yeah you guys have to watch this that
was on a celebrity rehab too well no no
she wasn't on celebrity but her dad was
on celebrity rehab yeah with uh dr drew
yeah yep
uh
going back and why is her dad a
celebrity
yeah because they're reaching yeah i
think it was like something with like
the um i'm sorry you don't like the
like something that like similar to like
what happened with like macaulay culkin
oh it was like a funny thing yeah with
the parents yeah yeah they have a law
about it i don't know
actually don't quote me on that jesus
but uh
but
whatever money a child makes in the film
industry goes into a bank account that
only they can activate upon turning
eighteen so somebody yeah have no sort
of any of that but i heard that still
kind of [ __ ] certain kids over because
once you turn like bella thorne had
talked about it where she entered bella
thorne she was a disney star uh she was
in a show with zendaya
i didn't even know i didn't even know
where she came from oh she like she was
sorry
yeah she was on a dance show uh she
basically made a bunch of money because
she was like uh bella thorne she was a
star on disney but then upon turning 18
she had a really uh terrible home life
and she basically
was forced to give up the money in some
way or another so she left disney and
was broke
she dated my son for a while too but
then she also oh she's left she also had
the only fans thing that like kind of
ruined it for everyone oh this is this
is the girl that created the only fans
and then you [ __ ] pretty much robbed
everybody but yeah and now they're like
different rules about how much someone
can spend on uh only fans now yeah
theo was in a music video with her harry
in the uh the bad baby music video oh
yeah was in that video yeah
online pervert
uh
going back to the
deuce bagel we don't have this yeah very
quickly um
amy poehler plays a uh narcoleptic that
he dated in it and we had this yeah that
was her we had this guy on this past
weekend who had
uh narcolepsy oh no they're yeah
no no wait there was another person no
amy poehler had
yeah she was like one of those
characters of that like he dated in the
moment yeah someone had narcolepsy but
someone had tourette's okay she was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah and then go out to
restaurants and yeah she was just saying
the words
are on narcolepsy
it's like two tracks going um
but uh
well
whatever uh yes so theo had a guy with
tourette's on
and
we did this thing just my idea was
pretty proud of it uh i pulled all these
like examples of tourette's from like
that
and
this old like magnum pi or something
yeah do you remember not a team movie
they had a cheerleader who had
tourette's damn i missed that one and i
love not another team movie
i remember that one that's great but i i
did south park this whole like magnum pi
or something weird and uh the guy did
not like the game
was he playing along at all yeah he
he he played like uh uh
he was weird he was he was trying to
recruit us for that nexium sex call he's
a weirdo oh god yeah yeah i remember you
telling us that wait why were you weird
about me saying narcolepsy i i didn't i
just never heard anyone say narcolepsy
before i thought it was just narcoleptic
i didn't like i didn't know that that
was the actual amazing word i was dumb
no i just didn't know that was an actual
word he thought i was dumb
and then you had to google it and found
out you were stupid all right
i'm trying to see the the redhead she
was cute
oh gosh
she's an entourage too she is who is she
how did you know that
oh
oh we're not talking about oh no that's
someone else that's an older actor
16 candles i'll drop kick you bro you're
the one who said who is she
i know who [ __ ] molly is this girl
that no there's someone no that she's
from reba she was the blonde one in that
clip oh you used to watch that show reba
yeah i loved reba
i seen her live is she good yeah
she was really good
that's cool yeah she's a legend yeah oh
yeah yeah
we have this thing back home in arizona
called country thunder yeah and uh i
went to it one year like back in 2004
and uh i think i saw
neil mccoy
um travis
tritt trap yeah charles tripp travis
trevor to be alive um reba mcintyre and
chris ledoux
those are the ones i saw chris ledoux
yeah
i think i've only i've only been to two
country concerts
that the country thunder and i went to
and i saw rascal flats
they're really
good he can sing or he or gary levox
yeah the lead singer or whatever that
guy
they can all go you know what i mean
lead singers not rascal
just kidding i did think that for a
while you know i think everybody
probably had a face with that yeah hey
country players
country uh country musicians good like
guitar players
are beasts yeah yeah
brad brad piece is amazing keith urban's
amazing yeah they can [ __ ] rip
consider i don't think he's considered
but there's a lot of country artists
that like to have a guitar there but
they don't really do anything
there's some beasts of guitar like
it's kind of beastly country
guitar players yeah
you know but you don't know for sure i
would like to believe that eric church
is one that plays the guitar i gotta i
gotta research eric and church more
because i don't really listen to his as
much
but seeing him actually play i kind of
feel like he just does like
chords he has old songs about like uh
can morgan rip well i guess he could
have been doing chords but he talks
about like playing playing on a bar
stool in like nashville
like at open mics and [ __ ] like for no
money he's got songs about it so oh
really but he could have been just doing
cool yeah
so he probably plays decent but as far
as like amazing yeah
like noted for specifically yeah brad
paisley can morgan wallin get down i
don't know i'm not sure i thought i
talked about another morgan no more than
walling
i craig morgan i think can you get him
on my show no we've been trying right
really yeah
but you've like been reaching out and
stuff no i've never reached out to him i
don't know like that see uh theo always
booked that directly huh theo and him
book directly like they talk to each
other yeah you'll probably get a
response you should everyone should
reach out to first his like two boys uh
um
they like started a podcast they're like
his writing partners uh those two guys
um look up uh eric or
uh morgan wallin writing partners dude
these are two dudes the varsity players
i even bet i i bet if you just reach out
to these guys they you get a response
from them and have them on
first does it say yeah is it i can't
read that but i think that's it
tyler hubbard
kelly jordan
i'm talking about
wallace wrote the
those guys it's like one guy goes by one
name and he's like like madonna here we
go ernest ernest
it says ernest interview
but the guy's name is actually earnest
that guy
yeah ernest
is it all like in cat blocks
okay that guy he like started a podcast
in nashville
and yeah he's boys with morgan like it's
those those he came on with morgan uh
when they um
i'll reach out to them they were on this
past weekend
yeah
one name is his handle actually earnest
that's how do you get that i don't know
i wonder if he had he got like pr to do
that um
i always love that when people have that
like jimmy tatro do you guys know who he
is
uh
he's like a youtuber who's also been in
like american vandal on netflix and
his big project that not a lot of people
have seen because it's on facebook is
real bros of semi valley which is
hilarious yes yes yes super [ __ ]
funny that guy yes uh his his handle is
just jimmy
it's so it's so nice i try to get my
name because i don't have a very common
name but it's already taken by like a 21
year old from like uc santa barbara he
is is he in uh oh no it's like cat teen
like his actual name the king of staten
island right he's been he's been doing a
lot of acting stuff right oh yeah
yeah
yeah i'm sorry sorry he's been in a lot
of stuff to say he was a youtuber
yeah he's killing it he's been really
killing him
he's like the show runner of that real
bros of semi-valley show and it's got
like a i don't know a staff of like over
100 people tell you you look like justin
timberlake uh no i'll take that though
you i get that are you saying that
i get that a lot
he's like settle down but you get that a
lot a lot come on i swear to god i see
it i see it
i literally on tick tock before my
account got banned
i would get that so much that i changed
my username to not justin timberlake as
a joke
you should have leaned into it and done
only justin timberlake
the real yeah
yeah yeah
would you say cat like the fake tom
cruise you know the guy who's the deep
fake yeah the deep fake yeah people
really say justin timberlake yeah maybe
it's just him like from bad teacher
he was so good at bad teacher i know he
wasn't he
i forgot he could that character was so
funny
see that one to the right where your
cursor is that looks that i see that as
looking like christian oh christian
no
i see it i see nick davis you're just
racist do you say i look like every
white kid on tv
just every white guy every other wedding
if you bring red hair on justin
timberlake i think you'll see it
just gotta photoshop him as a redhead
and then i don't have red hair i know i
agree when he was younger apparently no
way
bro all the kitty pictures you have of
you bro kitty what yeah whatever that
sounds
weird kitty picture it just sounds that
sounds weird sounds bad a little bit i'm
not gonna lie yeah i'll eat a dick
everybody
a kitty picture stop saying it it
doesn't make it better listen
i'm gonna keep kitty picture brown hair
that is [ __ ] red that's you yeah
that's me
looks completely different i know you
look different i would not but yeah i
would not be able to guess that was you
brown hair
again why do i feel like it's kind of
reddish too then see i have red
highlights but like kind of red
undertones i will say
yeah
there's some red in there
yo
i [ __ ] uh was looking at youtube
clips of that [ __ ] show that brendan
was talking about um
with the girl who's got a body
she's a 22 year old girl that has she's
trapped in a little girl's body her name
is
but no she likes the orphan yeah that
movie minus the murderous
aspects of it just like older woman
stuff shawna shauna is her body
i i love
she she just got a show on tlc that's
why
we know about it but it's so [ __ ]
just
like and i don't mean it like when i say
disturbing i don't mean to like
disrespect her because it's like so that
that's her she's 22 years old
and she's 3 10.
rose what do you want is money watching
her vape and [ __ ]
she's like
on a stripper pole yeah
oh a dude
there's one part of her like twerking
i'm like bro we gotta cut this off yeah
it was [ __ ] i was like bro we can't
watch this
it's it's so [ __ ] weird it is weird
it's disturbing i don't ever remember
that being on the episode chapel so
no chappelle researched it a little more
after this
i was saying i don't remember we talked
about her yeah but i don't remember
seeing no i said i went home and watched
it
oh
all right that is terrifying isn't that
crazy i think i think uh that's true
this week this is my favorite dumpster i
know yeah she just said brother yo nick
she got tattoos and [ __ ] oh yeah look at
her drinking the beer look at your beard
yeah but you know what's so funny about
her tattoos
they all look like a tattoo
like a little crazy right
she doesn't like look that yet like her
face obviously looks young in that like
it doesn't look that insane in this
because i don't know what it is like
that's an eight-year-old with a beer
oh dude that black dude she went on a
blind date with that black dude how'd it
go uh he i mean they just talked she
seemed yeah but like because he was just
like did he know ahead of time about
like no it was a blind date oh
no preface about no he didn't know that
guy didn't know anything he didn't know
anything well you saw this episode yeah
well
there's a bunch of like youtube clips we
need to download tlc did you trip out
that was like oh [ __ ] no he was just
like
she was like oh i have a disease or you
know she explained herself or whatever
he's like show me your eyes
[Laughter]
yeah disease
but it's so crazy she's had boyfriends
before though
you have the disease sir
we just need to set her up with house
bull or something like that
yeah
and he's an older there it is right
there
well
yeah that's gonna go uh where can they
find uh you christian everybody
everybody get a plug in
you can find me uh see palo 6 on
instagram and that's about it and your
local kkk meeting yeah yeah
we're putting those off here a little
bit so
next week kai um you can find me on
instagram at kyle varney with a v um
underscore
and i'm tagged on a lot of stuff so you
probably find me there easier
worry nick
thanks
would have felt weird just exactly
uh another podcast show that's that's uh
the show i've been doing for like a year
with two other guys our spin-off of the
bachelor specific show and below deck
specific show you've heard me talk about
a lot but we do a lot of fun [ __ ] on
there
chen
shinsuyi everywhere that's it
just google chinsy i have a youtube have
instagram of all stuff
don't vlog still vlogging thanks bro
the only thing that matters
onlyfans.comteen3i3es go buy some photos
of my feedback
subscribe to this super cast you get
fifty percent off cats only fans too i
heard
uh chappelle's world uh
yeah chappelle's work baby everybody
big boy network uh
you know
also uh
yeah man yeah me singer are you are you
are you
yeah oh yeah february 25th and 26th i'll
be in kansas city missouri at the comedy
club of kansas city i'll just plug that
one for right now we got to do that at
the end of the first half actually
because
oh yeah yeah uh maybe we'll try to
slice it in but yeah we're gonna put up
numbies though you'll move some tickets
yeah i know yeah please buy tickets to
my [ __ ] shows huh also buy his merch
i love it jerk faces by my merch love is
tight i'm doing a february drop for the
for the month of love in black history
month also i will say your merch very
high quality like stuff like i legit
wear your merch all the time
yeah
like i sleep that sweater that you gave
me uh when we did that photo shoot
yeah like every time it's clean i'm
always wearing it yeah that's what i
wanted thank you guys i appreciate that
that's tight that's a good one in my
[ __ ] huh you don't wear any of my [ __ ]
let's do an episode where everyone's
wearing your merch yeah give us some
wear the purple one got that
christian yeah we'll plug your uh
valentine's day line okay cool perfect
yeah well don't you might buy this one
now can i say bye
bye you don't want to say bye yeah sign
us up oh yeah hey i'm signing off
[Music]
you